I'm Zachary Feinstein I'm a professor at
Washington University in st. Louis in
the department of electrical and systems
engineering and I've watched all the
Star Wars movies dozens of times doing
them in a single day all six I am Peter
coy economics editor of Bloomberg
Businessweek I did see the first Star
Trek movie and I've seen little bits of
some of the others start Star Wars
we are here talking about your paper
called it's a trap Emperor Palpatine is
poison pill there is a great disturbance
in the force my theory that I posit in
this paper is that Emperor Palpatine
planned it that if he were defeated
after the Battle of Endor in Episode six
there would be economic repercussions on
such a scale that the rebels would never
be able to take power in the episode
four they build the first Death Star and
that is where Luke Skywalker blows up
the Death Star Episode six there's the
second Death Star and that one again
gets blown up this time by Lando
Calrissian
so the sheer scale of the debt for
building two Death Star's in such a
short period on top of the fact that
there is no true central bank within the
Star Wars universe and the repercussions
of these joint events would truly be a
staggering loss to the Galactic economy
now will you say all this were you
getting this from it's not in the movies
is it no so it's coming from these books
from the movies from the TV shows and
you can choose whether you want to find
just what is considered canon and what
is kind of considered legend at this
point I chose to accept anything that
was in Canon as much as possible and
anything that's not canon I tried to
stay away from if I could at all avoid
it now let's just walk through the paper
a little bit perfect
I started out coming up with the price
of the Death Star so the first Death
Star was a hundred and forty kilometers
in diameter and this gave a cost of a
hundred and ninety-three quintillion
dollars for the first Death Star
the second Death Star was 900 kilometers
in diameter so I came up with a cost of
419 quintillion dollars for the second
Death Star how did you get from there to
mass financial chaos so the problem is
that the rebels killed Emperor Palpatine
and presumably do not have a financial
strategy for after they take power which
would cause the banks to have to write
off 515 point 5 quintillion assuming
that some of the debt on the first Death
Star was already paid off your argument
is essentially that the Rebel Alliance
couldn't possibly get its hands on the
levers of power and run the bureaucracy
of the galaxy successfully not
immediately so my contention is Emperor
Palpatine had this as a trap even if
they do attack they can't kill me they
have to make an orderly line of
succession so I am still going to be
safe so it's sort of mutually assured
destruction exactly if the rebels head
said you know what we're going to honor
these debts there still would have been
a financial crisis due to the lack of
Deposit Insurance due to the lack of a
lender of last resort when the two Death
Star's were destroyed nothing of
productive use disappeared from the
galaxy so you could argue that as soon
as those Death Star's were destroyed the
debt paying potential of the galaxy
increased the debt paying potential of
the galaxy would increase if there is a
government that could collect those
debts to collect those taxes this is
clearly a product of an obsessed person
after having gone so deep into the
economics of Finance
can you really just watch these movies
like a regular fan anymore I don't think
I ever watch these movies like a regular
fan whenever I watched TV shows or
movies and I see these type of questions
popping up I can't ignore it it's this
is my life